Is Robert Pattinson the best actor to play
the Caped Crusader in live action?
Does Kevin Conroy still reign supreme when
it comes to Batman voice actors?
And where does Adam West's droll straight
man figure into it all?
These are the movie versions of Batman ranked
worst to best.
The thing you really have to understand about
the original Batman serials is that they're
bad.
Not just bad in retrospect after 70 years
of advancements in filmmaking and special
effects, although they certainly fit that
bill pretty handily.
No, they're just bad.
The first serial, released by Columbia in
15 parts, amounts to four and a half hours
of the worst version of Batman to ever hit
the silver screen.
Batman and Robin, played by Lewis Wilson and
Douglas Croft, are recast as government agents
who joined up to help the war effort and are
tasked with stopping the villainous Dr. Daka
from building a death ray.
In theory, that's a pretty exciting plot.
Unfortunately, the actual execution is atrocious.
It somehow winds up being repetitive even
by the standards of serials, with alarmingly
bad special effects, hilariously awkward costumes,
unconvincing fights, and, of course, a massive
helping of racism to bring it all together.
Overall, this is a Batman best forgotten.
The best thing you can say about 1949's "Batman
and Robin" is that it's not as racist as its
predecessor.
Unfortunately, that's about all you can say.
Robert Lowery's Batman stumbles from one goofy
cliffhanger to the next in an attempt to unmask
a mad scientist called the Wizard.
Four hours later, it turns out to be exactly
who you thought he was.
We'll take "hilariously silly" over "upsettingly
racist" any day of the week, but the fact
remains that Lowery's bumbling, barely present
Batman is trapped in a pretty awful plot that
stretches out even longer than the first serial.
The worst part, though, is the costume: a
straight up sweatsuit capped off with an ill-fitting
cowl.
Every now and then, an idea comes along that
seems like an absolute no-brainer.
Such is the case with the casting of Peter
Weller as the older Batman drawn out of retirement
in the animated adaptation of Frank Miller's
groundbreaking "Dark Knight Returns."
It sounds so good on paper, right?
An older, more brutal, and even angrier Batman,
played by the guy who brought his voice to
the title role of "RoboCop."
It's such a perfect idea that it's hard to
argue that they should've done anything else.
Unfortunately, the idea is the only part that's
perfect.
Whether it's Weller's unfamiliarity with the
art of voice acting or the desired effect
from director Jay Oliva, Weller sounds in
every scene like he just woke up.
He might actually be the worst part of the
film.
Rather than a dynamic growl that goes with
the action, Weller winds up just being boring,
and whatever problems you might have with
The Dark Knight Returns, "boring" should not
be one of them.
"You are slow."
"True.
But we're all slow when we're thigh deep in
mud."
Bruce Greenwood can best be described as the
2003 Toyota Corolla of Batman actors.
Nothing fancy, no real features to speak of,
and it doesn't quite have the appeal of the
older classic models or newer, better ones,
but it'll get you where you're going.
Okay, so maybe that's a harsh way of putting
it, but it's pretty accurate.
Greenwood has played Batman on multiple occasions
— three DTV movies, a videogame and the
"Young Justice" TV show — and it's probably
telling that there's only one of those, the
adaptation of "Gotham by Gaslight," where
he's the focus.
Even then, the emphasis is less on Batman
as a character than it is on the idea of seeing
all the familiar characters recast in the
Victorian era setting of a story in which
Batman fights Jack the Ripper.
The others are all focused on different characters,
and in the case of "Under the Red Hood," Greenwood
is playing Batman opposite "Supernatural"
star Jensen Ackles, whose performance as Jason
Todd is so full of charisma that he quickly
upstages his co-star.
"You don't understand.
I don't think you've ever understood."
"What?
Your moral code just won't allow for that?"
Since actor Jensen Ackles did such a bang-up
job as Jason Todd in 2010's animated adaptation
of "Under the Red Hood," he got his chance
as the Caped Crusader himself in a pair of
"Long Halloween" adaptations in 2021.
Unfortunately, Ackles showed his talents weren't
quite the fit for Batman that many had anticipated.
Ackles delivers a stock standard Wayne and
slightly gruffer Dark Knight;
"Attacking us like that, out in the open…
It didn't fit the profile."
Troy Baker, ironically enough, becomes the
hero of this adaptation by giving an excellent
Hamill impersonation as the Joker.
David Dastmalchian likewise offers up a genuinely
chilling performance here as Calendar Man.
This arc features most of Batman's rogues
gallery appearing in one way or another, each
character playing their own small role.
If you're a Batman fan, it's a must-watch;
just don't expect Ackles' work here to give
you any new insight into the character.
On paper, Ben Affleck seems like a pretty
solid choice for Batman.
He's got those square-jawed good looks and
he's more than capable of bringing a deep
focus and intensity to roles when they call
for it.
In practice, though, the Batman of "Dawn of
Justice" is only saved from being the worst
superhero in his universe because Superman
is somehow even worse.
It's worth noting that much of director Zack
Snyder's inspiration came from Frank Miller's
landmark story "The Dark Knight Returns."
Unfortunately, while the movie recreated entire
scenes wholesale from the comics, they're
all divorced from their original context.
Affleck's Batman is a ludicrously violent
murderer who's easily manipulated into a fistfight
with another superhero—a fistfight that
ends when the person he's fighting reminds
him that other people also have moms.
You'd think that would be something he would've
learned in his years as the World's Greatest
Detective.
"What does that mean?
Why did you say that name?"
The animated adaptation of Frank Miller and
Dave Mazzucchelli's "Batman: Year One" fares
a little better than "The Dark Knight Returns"
for a few reasons, but the casting of its
title character was not one of them.
Ben McKenzie approaches the role of a young
Bruce Wayne trying to figure out how best
to fight crime with what can only be described
as the monotone delivery of a sexy robot.
Seriously, we've tried to think of other ways
to describe it, but that is unquestionably
the best one.
"You've eaten well.
You've eaten Gotham's wealth, its spirit,
but your feast is nearly over."
All of the intensity and emotion of key scenes
from the original, like being inspired by
the bat crashing through his window or announcing
his presence to Gotham's wealthy white-collar
criminals, is lost in favor of the sensual
monotony of some kind of pleasure droid.
Once you have that image in your head, it
does make McKenzie's Batman a little more
interesting, but it doesn't rescue the performance.
Instead, ironically enough, Batman winds up
being overshadowed by another "Year One" main
character, Jim Gordon, who's played here by
Bryan Cranston in a role that McKenzie would
get a few years later as the star of "Gotham."
"It's been years since I had to take out a
green beret.
Even so, he deserves a handicap."
"Crisis on Two Earths" was one of the earlier
entries into the ever-expanding roster of
DC Universe Animated Original Movies, and
generally speaking, it's also one of the best.
It was loosely based on some classic JLA stories,
giving it a solid foundation.
It was written by the late Dwayne McDuffie,
who was the story editor for "Justice League
Unlimited."
It even has some great fight scenes and solid
visuals that are a step above what viewers
would get later.
In fact, pretty much everything about the
movie is great...
except Batman.
It was a weird bit of stunt casting to get
William Baldwin to play the Dark Knight, but
he's not really bad in the part.
He just never really sounds like Batman, in
a way that's difficult to pin down.
"What was so valuable that the Crime Syndicate
would cross dimensions to get it?"
"Did you keep it from her?"
"Her henchman escaped with it.
Whatever it was."
Maybe it's just that this feels like a lost
episode of "Justice League," which makes it
a little weird that it's not Kevin Conroy's
voice coming out of Batman.
Maybe it's that this appears to be Baldwin's
very first voice acting gig, giving him some
intangible quality that sounds a little off.
Whatever it is, it's just not quite right.
2021's "Soul of the Dragon" is another modern
DC animated outing that recasts the Dark Knight,
and it has a lot of good things going for
it — even if the least impressive of them
is its take on Batman.
"Grimm" actor David Giuntoli gives a dry performance
as Bruce Wayne.
His Batman doesn't fare much less grim in
the rare instances he dons the cape at all;
this movie focuses as much on Mark Dacascos
doing his best Bruce Lee impression as Richard
Dragon, as it does on Bruce Wayne.
"We're in this together, Bruce.
Just like we've always been.
Like we're supposed to be.
We are the dragon."
This original Batman story was written by
"Animated Series" veteran Bruce Timm.
Set in the 1970s, "Soul of the Dragon" is
an R-rated-like take on martial arts films,
inspired largely by the Bruce Lee classic
"Enter the Dragon."
Of course, it takes cues from the martial
arts-heavy "Batman Begins" as well.
Overall, though, "Soul of the Dragon" is a
pretty good animated homage, if not necessarily
a great Batman movie.
The best way to describe "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D."
actor Jason O'Mara's take on Batman is this:
What would it sound like if George Clooney
had been allowed to be Batman in a much less
campy setting?
O'Mara's tone of voice is remarkably similar
to how Clooney sounded behind the cowl, even
if he isn't allowed to embrace his charisma
as fully as Clooney could.
The story of "Hush" is a strong one, as Batman
must uncover the identity of a mysterious
new killer in Gotham.
However, O'Mara delivers a confident, only
slightly brooding, take on the detective.
"The events of the past months reach as high
as Superman and as low as the Joker.
All were set into motion by Hush."
O'Mara would came back for 2020's solid "Justice
League Dark: Apokolips War," where he reprised
his role alongside a star-studded cast in
a very different, very violent sort of superhero
story.
But unfortunately, O'Mara's second shot at
the character wasn't enough to put him any
higher on this list.
First things first: Diedrich Bader is actually
a really good Batman.
In "Batman: The Brave and the Bold," he served
as a cheerless Batman.
His take was as a straight man for a cast
of superheroic oddballs in a series of team-ups
that spanned the entirety of the DC Universe.
Even the viewers who were initially put off
by the show's inherent silliness were won
over when the show veered into darkness with
"Chill of the Night."
"So just like that he signed away their lives,
so casually.
Without remorse.
Without blinking a filthy eye."
Here's the problem: there's no "Brave and
the Bold" movie to show off Bader's chops,
although he does get second billing in a straight-to-video
Scooby-Doo movie.
That just leaves "JLA Adventures: Trapped
In Time."
The story revolves around the Justice League
having to go back in time to save baby Superman
from being murdered by the Legion of Doom.
At one point it involves them literally throwing
the indestructible Kryptonian baby around
like a football.
Overall, though, it's pretty forgettable outside
of some truly bad costume designs, and none
of the things that made Bader's Batman work
are on display.
In the run-up to the release of 2019's "Joker,"
there was a lot commentary about how writer/director
Todd Philips had said that his take on the
title character with Joaquin Phoenix "didn't
follow anything from the comic books."
With that being the case, it was probably
pretty embarrassing for him to realize that
he accidentally put both the Joker and Bruce
Wayne, who is actually the comic book superhero
Batman, into the film.
Sure, technically, the little boy Bruce Wayne
doesn't suit up as a dark avenger of the night
or perform any of the ninja tricks Batman
is known for, but we're still counting him
for this list.
In fact, Dante Pereira-Olsen gives us an interesting
baseline for Bat-performances.
He definitely doesn't do anything wrong in
his portrayal of LI'l Batman, but that's mostly
because he doesn't really do anything, period.
His most memorable moment in the film comes
in a scene during which Bruce stands there
silently while a grown man puts his fingers
into Bruce's mouth and makes him "smile."
Pereira-Olson is perfectly fine for what he's
given to do, which is nothing, and the end
result is that this is the Bat-performance
equivalent of pure water: a completely value-neutral
baseline that we can use as our midpoint.
In virtually any other film, casting Jimmy
Kimmel as Batman would be downright alarming
for fans, provoking the kind of discourse
that would make Ben Affleck getting the part
look like a brief but civil debate.
In "Teen Titans Go!
To the Movies," however, it's not even in
the top five most notable casting choices.
The big one is almost certainly Nicolas Cage's
all-too-brief performance as Superman, both
because Cage was initially set to play the
Man of Steel in Tim Burton's "Superman Lives"
and because it's Nicolas Cage as Superman.
"I knew you were goofsters, but using Lois,
and now this?
It's too much!"
Compared to that, Kimmel as Batman doesn't
seem all that notable.
Or, to be honest, all that memorable.
Despite Batman being at the center of one
of the film's most notable moments, Kimmel
is ultimately very forgettable as Batman.
It's that rare case of a movie that just has
too much going on.
In a movie that's soaked in lime green neon
and hot pink leopard print, Val Kilmer's portrayal
of the Caped Crusader is... well, the kindest
way to put it would be "reserved," but let's
not mince words here.
Kilmer, only two years removed from a charismatic,
scene-stealing turn as Doc Holliday in "Tombstone,"
drifts through "Batman Forever" with the screen
presence of a cardboard cutout.
"What's wrong?"
To be fair, there was a good reason for him
to make that choice as an actor.
Director Joel Schumacher, Tim Burton's hand-picked
successor, was clearly drawing his inspiration
from the 1966 television show, and with Jim
Carrey and Tommy Lee Jones chewing their way
through every available bit of scenery, replicating
Adam West's straight man so they'd have something
to bounce off of probably seemed like the
best way to go.
There are parts where it actually works, too—the
best scenes by far in "Batman Forever" are
the ones in which Carrey's Edward Nygma tries
to dress, act, and sound like his idol, Kilmer's
Bruce Wayne.
For those, he's the perfect straight man for
the wildly over-the-top villains.
When it comes to actually being Batman, however,
Kilmer's Adam West impression just doesn't
land, whether it's battling against the villains,
giving Dick Grayson a home, or having a monumentally
tepid romance with Nicole Kidman's Dr. Chase
Meridian.
It just flat-out doesn't work.
If you're not familiar with "Batman Unlimited,"
that's probably because it's the reverse of
the way things usually work.
Rather than starting out with a movie or cartoon
and then creating toys based on that, this
one started out as an action figure line that
was created to keep kid-friendly Batman toys
in stores during the more PG-13 era of the
Christopher Nolan and Zack Snyder films.
Once the toys were out, a series of animated
shorts and a trio of direct-to-video movies
were released, and if you're into the weirder
side of Batman, they're well worth watching.
You might expect a movie that only exists
to support an action figure line to feature
a series of incredibly toyetic costumes, but
the "Unlimited" movies go a step further by
giving Batman a new sidekick in the form of
a robot wolf that turns into a motorcycle.They're
not exactly what you'd call "good," but they
are awesome.
"I am shooting a viral video here!"
Batman is brought to life this time courtesy
of veteran voice actor Roger Craig Smith.
It might seem counterintuitive to cast the
same guy who played Sonic the Hedgehog and
Thomas from "Regular Show" as Batman, but
he turns in a solid performance.
He definitely shows why he was brought back
to play the Caped Crusader in other projects,
like the English dub of "Batman: Ninja" and
most recently, 2020's "Superman: Red Son."
To say "Batman and Robin" has a bad reputation
is putting it about as mildly as you possibly
could.
Whether or not it deserves all the hate, it's
commonly regarded as one of the worst superhero
movies of all time, with a bloated cast of
villains and sidekicks sprawling out into
a plot that starts off silly and ends up verging
on ludicrous.
"I hate to disappoint you, but… rubber lips
are immune to your charms."
It's so bad that both Joel Schumacher and
George Clooney have apologized for it, and
it was credited with nearly killing the franchise
until it returned with a darker direction
under Christopher Nolan.
The thing is, as controversial as it might
sound, Clooney's not actually that bad in
the role of Bruce Wayne.
Like Affleck, he's an actor who was perfect
for the role on paper, a leading man on the
rise who brought an effortless charm to the
role.
The problem is that "effortless charm" doesn't
really work for Batman—but it ends up working
pretty well for Bruce Wayne.
Clooney's best work comes when he's out of
the costume, sweeping around Wayne Manor dealing
with Alfred's not-quite-fatal illness, or
in the few scenes where we see him as the
franchise's most convincing version of a celebrity
playboy to date.
Of all the actors to play Batman, Troy Baker
might be the most versatile.
He's the only actor to voice both Batman and
the Joker.
In "Batman vs. Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles,"
he plays them both in the same film, and he's
even been three different versions of Robin
in other movies.
He has range.
He even has range within the same character.
The version of Batman that he plays in the
kid-targeted "LEGO" movies is a slightly different
character than we get from the more serious
version in "Batman vs. Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles."
They're both recognizably Baker, who manages
to carve out a performance that's a little
more distinct from other voice actors.
The only real downside is that he often comes
off as a substitute for other actors.
His Joker, for instance, is very much filling
in for Mark Hamill, and his Batman could be
seen as a replacement for Kevin Conroy.
Still, Baker's Batman is incredibly solid.
He captures the threatening growl of the Dark
Knight while still having enough energy and
character to keep it from slipping into monotone.
It's arguable that his performance is what
makes "Batman vs. TMNT" work far better than
it has any right to.
Rino Romano's tenure on the animated show
"The Batman," despite lasting a respectable
five seasons, will always exist in the shadow
of its predecessor, "Batman: The Animated
Series," and will never be as fondly remembered.
That's a shame, too.
He might not be as definitive as Kevin Conroy,
but Romano is actually very good in the part.
As a younger Batman, Romano's got a little
more lightness and energy to his performance,
but still keeps the gravelly menace that comes
along with the cape and cowl.
Romano's one full-length adventure, the spooky,
made-for-TV "The Batman vs. Dracula," is an
enjoyable movie in its own right, and even
works as a showcase for the redesigned Penguin
and Joker.
Still, for the epic confrontation between
bat-themed good guy and a vampire bad guy,
it's not quite as good as you want it to be,
especially since that story's been told with
more panache elsewhere.
That's Romano's role in a nutshell: if we
didn't have anything to compare it to and
could judge it entirely on its own merits,
he'd be great.
Director Matt Reeves took a big chance in
casting an actor many viewers mainly know
as a "Twilight" vampire, Robert Pattinson.
But as the months of production went by, the
concept of Pattinson Batman won over fans.
Pattinson's Bruce Wayne is not only younger-looking
than fans have come to expect from the character,
but he's also decidedly more awkward around
people.
In case the Nirvana needle-drops didn't get
the point across, this man is filled with
angst, regret and a healthy dose of self-loathing.
He clings to his virtuous vigilante mission
as Batman, referring to himself as a "nocturnal
animal," determined to clean up the streets.
In a film heavily influenced by '70s cinema,
will he soar like Brewster McCloud or go off
the deep end like Travis Bickle?
As Batman, Pattinson's jaw is the best since
Kilmer.
But his quirky decisions and physicality feel
more like Michael Keaton, without the Tim
Burton polish.
This is a World's Greatest Detective who makes
mistakes, gets teased over the declaration,
"I'm vengeance."
…and punctuates a daring escape by deploying
his parachute too quickly and slamming into
the pavement.
He's flawed, and that's interesting.
There's a moment in "Batman Begins" that really
captures the intensity Christian Bale brings
to his performance as Batman:
"Where were the other drugs going?"
"I never knew!
I don't know!
I swear to G--"
"Swear to me!"
Bale's Batman brings that intensity to everything
he does, showing an emotional range that stretches
from the righteous fury of Batman to the aimless
pain of the orphaned Bruce Wayne.
It's a power that's only ever matched when
he goes up against Heath Ledger's Joker, one
of the best performances in the genre.
The detective part of the package might be
a little lacking, but the way Bale plays off
of his costars and paints a picture of a man
torn between using his rage to fuel his mission
and letting it consume him is genuinely incredible.
The fact that he does it all while speaking
in a voice that sounds like he's chewing rusty
nails?
That's just icing on the cake.
Unlike every other actor on this list, Will
Friedle doesn't play Bruce Wayne.
He plays Terry McGinnis, a teenager from a
cyberpunk future who takes over the role in
"Batman Beyond."
Along with a killer costume design and the
best version of a retired Bruce Wayne, Friedle's
performance is one of the biggest reasons
why "Batman Beyond" works.
The way he switches from Terry's normal, lighter
speaking voice to the growly Batman voice
that he uses is distinct without ever feeling
like he's going too far over the top with
it.
He's also an extremely likable character in
a way that Bruce's Batman never really is.
Terry seems more like a human being and less
like the peak ideal of human perfection who
is also very grumpy about it.
The only thing that's holding him back is
that his only film appearance comes in "Batman
Beyond: Return of the Joker," which has a
very different tone from the "Batman Beyond"
TV series.
It's one of the darkest things that DC has
ever done with their animated properties,
to the point where some pretty graphic scenes
were heavily edited for its first release.
That said, it's still a well-done and extremely
engaging movie.
It's just not a good showcase of what makes
Friedle, and Terry, so good in their roles.
The Tim Burton Batman movies have an incredible
visual style, with a Gotham City that's hellish
urban sprawl come to life, full of buildings
with exposed ductwork and piping stacked up
next to Art Deco sculptures.
They're also full of great bits of satire,
beautiful shots, and amazingly offbeat casts.
Whether they're good Batman movies is a point
of debate, and no one really captures that
disconnect more than Michael Keaton.
He's actually kind of perfect for the kind
of remote, mysterious weirdo who sleeps upside
down because he wants to be more like a bat.
"Now you wanna get nuts?
Come on!
Let's get nuts!"
But there's a disconnect between the stylized
goofiness that Burton explored in his earlier
films and the '80s action movie aesthetic
that saw Keaton's Batman throwing people off
buildings and blowing up factories with bombs.
It's not really portrayed as heroism, but
as a personal quest for vengeance that only
incidentally winds up saving a city.
Keaton does well in the role, but his Batman
is missing some key components other versions
of the character nail.
An ultra-competent, self-absorbed superhero
who writes heavy metal songs about being a
sad orphan and is seemingly able to appear
at will as soon as no one's looking?
The LEGO version of Batman is one of those
rare finds: a parody of something that actually
works pretty well as the thing itself.
"Batman is very wise.
I also have huge pecs and a nine-pack.
Yeah, I've got an extra ab."
Will Arnett's Batman only builds things out
of black bricks and Arnett ramps up his naturally
gravelly voice into a spoof of Christian Bale's.
At the same time, though, he's very rarely
presented as anything other than extremely
good at what he does, and he really does act
heroically, even if his heroism occasionally
means that Han Solo gets eaten by a space
worm.
Either way, it works.
While other portrayals might move away from
the inherent silliness of the character, embracing
it gives the LEGO version a flavor that helps
him rival even the best of his big-screen
contemporaries.
The best thing about Adam West's performance
as Batman is that it can mean completely different
things depending when you watch it.
As a child, it's easy to buy West's spandex-clad
squareness as completely genuine.
As an adult, you get the joke.
The fact that he was able to play the perfect
straight man for a wild cast of villains is
every bit as astonishing as those surface-level
comic book thrills.
The 1966 movie released between the first
two seasons of the "Batman" TV series has
everything, in a very literal sense.
The arch-villains are four of his greatest
foes brought together as the United Underworld,
complete with a sequence in which Batman and
Robin identify their enemies through truly
profound leaps of logic.
"But wait!
It happened at sea!
See?
C for Catwoman!"
It also features West using the role of Bruce
Wayne as an attempt to draw his enemies out
into the open, miraculously turning his carefully
modulated tone into barely controlled rage
at the threat to his love interest, Miss Kitka.
And the heartbreak in his eyes when he discovers
that she was Catwoman all along?
It's a surprisingly powerful moment.
No actor has ever been as strongly identified
with the role of Batman as Adam West, and
the movie shows exactly why.
His performance walks the delicate balance
between full-hearted adventure and witty satire
that the material does, and the end result
is perfect.
Yes, this one is a bit of a cheat.
Kevin Conroy has, after all, been the most
prominent Batman actor for over 25 years,
making his debut on "Batman: The Animated
Series" and staying in the role in many of
the DC animated movies and the "Arkham" video
games.
But there's a good reason: Conroy is an amazing
Batman, and everything that makes him great
is on display in "Mask of the Phantasm."
One of the great things about "The Animated
Series" was that it gave us a version of Batman
that was already fully formed, saving the
origin stories for a handful of villains like
Two-Face and the Riddler.
For the film, though, the origin story is
a crucial component, and Conroy's performance
sells it beautifully.
The scene when he's standing in front of his
parents' graves, pleading with them to understand
he may give up being Batman because he's finally
found happiness, might sound ridiculous.
But in practice, it's devastatingly emotional.
"I know I made a promise, but I didn't see
this coming.
I didn't count on being happy."
When that happiness is taken away and Batman
gives himself over to his mission entirely?
It's fantastic.
For a generation of Batman fans, Conroy's
is the voice they hear in their heads when
they read comics, and that alone should show
just how great he was.
It takes an incredible amount of talent to
redefine the character, but Conroy did it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.